en Bolivia el gobierno de Luis Arce ha
tomado la decisión de suspender sin
fecha la obligatoriedad de presentar el
carnet de vacunación en diferentes
espacios públicos y privados luego de
que diversos grupos anti vacunas
protagonizaron protestas desde este
lunes en la ciudades de la paz y
Cochabamba al extremo de que en esta
última capital se han registrado
enfrentamientos con la policía el
gobierno ha señalado que la suspensión
de esta medida rige solamente mientras
dure la emergencia sanitaria de la
pandemia y que una vez que esta
emergencia termine la obligatoriedad
regresará pero con varias salvedades Por
ejemplo ya no será obligatorio presentar
este pase sanitario para ingresar a los
mercados a los supermercados a los
centros de salud e incluso para
inscribir a los niños en las escuelas
hay que recordar que estos grupos
antivacunas que han estado protestando
muchos son afines al gobierno de Luis
arce y han puesto contra la pared a las
autoridades luego que se emitiera este
decreto que obliga a presentar el carnet
de vacunación en diferentes espacios
públicos y privados